hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the neurobiology of
temperament and mood I am Brenda Kelly
Kim I'll be your moderator for today's
laberd's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab routes the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning before we
start there are a few instructions we
want to hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment answers
are always welcome - you can do this by
hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll we'll follow up if we
don't have time today want a better look
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can hear or see this presentation
properly please let us know by clicking
on the support button in the top right
or use the Q&A button we'll make sure we
try to resolve any issues this is an
educational webinar and thus author
Street continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C e button located on the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the instructions to claim your
credits now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome dr.
Hooda upfield
who da keel is a neuroscientist whose
pioneering research has contributed to
the understanding of neurobiology of
emotions she was born in Damascus Syria
and was educated in Lebanon and the
United States of America she is the
co-director of the molecular and
Behavioral Neuroscience Institute with
Stanley Watson and the Gardner safe work
and distinguished professor of
neurosciences in the department of
psychiatry at the University of Michigan
Medical School she is also the
co-director of the University of
Michigan note of the Pritzker
neuropsychiatric disorders Research
Consortium her undergraduate education
was at the American University of Beirut
she completed doctoral work at the
University of California Las
postdoctoral work Stanford University
she's a former president of the Society
for Neuroscience from 2002 to 2003 and
she's an elected member of the National
Academy of Sciences I will now turn it
over to dr. keel for her presentation
morning today the topic of my
presentation is the neurobiology of
temperament and rule and more
specifically it's about whether we can
think of better animal models for the
study of humans psychiatric and edifieth
disorders I would like to start by
acknowledging that this work is the
result of a very active team that
includes dr. Stanley Watson and group
that we call the Joaquin's for a
combination of Watson and Akhil and I
have listed the name of the current
members of our research groups at the
moment but there were also very
important people who have contributed in
the past where in the lab in the past
and contributed to some of this story
that I will be telling you about today
some of them we're in charge of a rat
colony I'll be telling you about the
rats today that are kind of unique and
special I'll be spending a lot of time
talking about them and these folks John
said Sarah Clinton Peter Blandino and
currently Helen have the power are in
charge of the rat colony and then there
are a number of past trainees whose work
I will be describing Mohammed kabosh and
flagel Javier parez and then a number of
collaborators here at Michigan and
elsewhere that I have listed in
particular the frisco consortium is a
very unusual large team across the
entire country that is more focused on
the human side and I will get back to
what we have done together of relevance
to this talk a little bit later today so
our goal is to understand the brain
biology of emotions and mood and how
that is relevant how that helps us
understand psychiatric and addictive
disorders and so we want to understand
how we code stress how we cope with
stress how the reactivity in the brains
biology reactivity to all of that
affects who gets a mood disorders how
long that would disorder laugh
and also who is prone to addiction and
how long that addiction stays with the
person and we rely both on animal models
and human studies but I'm focusing more
on the animal side today so first of all
a word about mood disorders
the severe mood disorders affect 20
million Americans and cost and
staggering fifty billion dollars a year
a mood disorder is probably the single
most typical description is that it is
emotionally very painful for people they
have a sense of helplessness a sense of
hopelessness and then a series of other
symptoms that vary a great deal from one
person to another some of them are not
just emotional cognitive they can
concentrate some of them are physical
they are not able to sleep or you know
they either gain weight or lose weight
and there are multiple types of mood
disorders some are called unipolar which
is the most common which is major
depression and the others sometimes it's
called manic-depressive illness or more
formally bipolar disorder that anxiety
chronic anxiety disorders PTSD and many
others panic and so on then on the other
side there is substance abuse disorders
and those can be
alcoholism or abuse of prescription
drugs of street drugs and again
addictive disorders are extremely
devastating they are even more expensive
because of all the criminal aspects
associated with them and there is beyond
the drug abuse the issue of gambling
overeating and other types of addictions
about the same number as depression 22
million Americans meet criteria for
substance abuse including alcohol and
nicotine and a subset of them have much
more severe types of alcohol
I mean drug abuse types like addictive
addiction to cocaine
one thing that is remarkable right off
the bat and I'm gonna use substance
abuse as my example is this idea of
individual differences that not
everybody reacts the same way so of the
many people who experiment with drugs
only 10 to 15 percent will become
addicted in a lifelong way and we do not
understand what that is that makes some
people more prone to addiction than
others and that's really part of the
discussion today is not what happens
after the drugs or the disease hits the
brain the mood disorder but more what is
it that makes some people more
vulnerable and other people more
resilient and can we understand this at
the biological and molecular level so
typically people want to study genetics
and they say well there are genes they
change your odds of having one disorder
on another and that leads to your
disease in various episodes but in fact
it has been rather hard to directly link
single gene or even a handful of gene to
the disorder so even though there's been
a lot of effort a lot of money the
simple-minded
approach to the genetics of these
disorders has been has met with some
success but limited success so the
question is why that is are we are the
genes the right level of analysis and a
few years ago I participated in sort of
the for piece about this issue and we
argued in this paper that I'm showing
here that the future of psychiatric
research it lies in thinking
simultaneously about the genetics and
about brain circuits and that we need to
integrate that information together and
the reason is that the there is a brain
sitting between the genes and the
disease and the brain will not just be
quiet and go quietly in the night and
not play a role the the brain first of
all integrates the relationship
between genes and environments so the
genes are not destiny they don't
automatically create a program for the
rest of the person's life environment
matters and so the place where gene and
environment meet is at the level of the
brain but also there are a lot of other
kind of events that beyond you know when
we say environment there are lots of
events some of those are in early life
so called developmental event
interaction with a mother later on
through our youth and adolescence there
is also stress in adulthood and we know
that a lot of these disorders are
affected by adult stress and that
creates the disease and then there is
the fact that the illness itself comes
back and remodels the brain so these
neural remodeling processes these are
the results of the disease itself so
even if two people have our identical
twins have identical genetics and by
some miracle have exactly the same
environmental mirror that they grow up
in if somebody gets more stressed and
becomes ill then that brain is going to
change very differently from their twin
brother or sister because the process of
the stress and the illness will change
their brain and so the the the to go
back to the question of individual
differences should we just be thinking
about genes or should we be thinking
about the brain and if when we're
thinking about the brain before somebody
gets still should we be thinking that
different brain circuits are tuned
differently that there is a natural
variation in how we are wired even
though we are all called normal that
there are different types of normal and
that for certain functions like thinking
and feelings and coping it's actually
good that not all creatures are tuned
exactly the same way because of the
world for a species the world is not
always the same so sometimes it's good
for example to be at
sure some for the species because those
numbers of the species are going to go
out and discover new things or new mates
or new food but sometimes there is a lot
of threat and so it's the members of the
species that are not conservative that
I'm going to survive better and that
means if there are different brain
circuits for normal cocaine they're
going to malfunction a little bit
differently so if human disorders
represent variations from the norm
should we not study how variations occur
in our animal models now most animal
models don't really look at variations
in them in the lab most people want
things to be as consistent as possible
but in fact in the clinical world and
even in normal psychology of humans what
is very clear is that humans from the
beginning from the get-go are very very
different from each other and a famous
test is called the marshmallow test
that's done in little kids
it is extremely predictive of how people
emotionally regulate later in life if
you have a chance go just google the
marshmallow test it will start it back
and Stanford in the 1970s and it's a
simple cute little test with you gonna
go back and tell you about it if you
give a marshmallow to err like a four or
five-year-old kid put it in front of
them and say if you wait for five seven
minutes you can get two marshmallows but
if you eat it now that's all you're
gonna get
that's delayed gratification some kids
can wait some kids cannot wait and some
kids wait but they suffer in rem
incredibly during the waiting they want
to lick it like you know smell it they
just look away from it they have a whole
lot of trouble
so that has actually predicts later on
in life who is going to be able to
control their impulses and who is that
and another test is about emotional
reactivity it was done as a toy test by
Jerome king
and about you being a kid a baby in a
series of toys and you give them a bunch
at a time and do you overwhelm them or
do they think it's fun a baby who is
very easily overwhelmed by stimulation
can be at higher risk for developing
anxiety disorders later in life
so this description describes something
we call complement sometimes it's called
personality this is a program that it is
either genetic or developmental that is
there very early in life and seems to
predict how we respond to the
environment around us and it is there
because it's a program of reactivity to
the world so it's both about genes and
environment it makes it hard to separate
nature and nurture because it's all
bundled up in this response to the world
and there is a genetic stew that is what
we are arguing and our framework is that
these differences in emotional
reactivity actually predicts who is
going to be responsive to life when
things go wrong in which direction so
when people do the genetics they don't
find genetics of one disease versus
another very specifically but they find
genetics that are related to whether you
are more prone to anxiety and depressive
responses versus you are prone to more
aggressive psychopathic or substance
abuse responses so those are called
internalizing disorders if you're kind
of aiming the negative stuff towards
yourself you're feeling bad about
yourself you're anxious you're depressed
versus externalizing disorder when
something is wrong you take it out on
the outside world use the drugs you can
get angry etc so the question is is the
biology of temperament related to the
propensity for internalizing and
externalizing disorder so I told you
these disorders are
their characteristics but before hands
there is also other characteristics of
people prone to these disorders so
people who are likely to have
externalizing this order are likely to
like novelty like risks and thrill
seeking to be a little more impulsive
now and for internalizing disorders they
tend to be overly controlled the the
thing that's really important to stress
is that these are at the extremes but
when you look at them in the more normal
range this can be very positive traits
people can be taking risks in a positive
way or they can be more like thoughtful
and careful but also you know very
compassionate for example so it's only
at the extremes that these traits become
problematic but there are some examples
of for example kids doing active sports
and there was a recent article I think
in the near I'm saying is it bad to let
your kids go jumping and flipping and
running around and when they interview
the kids you know like climb rocks and
do all of this that what they find is
that people say I love to be scared
I like being scared so there are some
humans that just love the sensation of
these kid it's not that they don't feel
scared they find that exciting and
that's something really haven't thought
about very much in the animal world
world how do you model that and what
does it predict when something does go
wrong versus people who hate being
scared
so the first attempt at looking at this
issue came from the world of Piazza and
his colleagues back in 1989 where they
studied a very simple behavior in the
lab and far they that they use it to
predict who is more likely to what
amphetamine to self-administer
amphetamine as in a rat so what they did
is they took animals and threw them in a
new place and asked
just love a new place even though they
don't know what it's going to pain
whether it's gonna be scary or not but
they'll go ahead and explore it while
other animals are very scared and the
answer is there are vast differences
between rats in this behavior and when
you look at those differences you just
buy those rats from lab suppliers
they're very different and the ones that
love to explore will also experiment
with drugs wrong when you give them that
opportunity so this is here now work
from our own showing the behavioral
phenotype the way it looks and the red
marks show the movement of an animal in
a new place with a new object in the
middle on the left is something called
the high responder laughs always nice to
go that's why it's labeled in green like
the traffic light and you can see the
lines are all over this face where is on
the right the right the low responsive
rat barely even makes the perimeter hugs
the walls sits in the corner so that is
called high and low responders that
spontaneous we have never taught them
anything and animals reliably on one way
or another
that's novelty seeking behavior you can
quantify their locomotion in how much
they explore the first few minutes you
can see some real differences between
them and then when you take these very
animals and you give them a chance to
press a bar and get some cool
amphetamine into them the high responder
rats in green immediately take the drug
and the low responder rats take maybe 10
days before they start to experiment so
that that reliable difference is out
there we could replicate that finding
so we said as our is there a genetic and
brain basis that we can understand for
this tendency and what else comes along
with these traits of liking to explore
so we started a genetic breeding program
and that is like not that different from
animals so from people who've read dogs
or horses or whatever but we did it in
rats and we did this simple test where
we put them in a new place and
as they'd like to explore or are they
shy and we bred the high explorers to
each other and the timid animals with
each other now when within a family
always lost many families so that we
wouldn't get too much inbreeding and we
have now had them actually for almost 50
generations it's been ten years that
we've been reading them and in green the
high responders get more and more so you
know more and more exploratory very very
active in their locomotion in the place
and the low responders get more and more
nervous and timid over the generations
and so again when you look at them with
this coating of the light and their
movement you can see really big
differences and below is a review by
flavor at all summarizing a lot of the
work on this hi and notice father labs
so our argument is the red hot look at
so the B means selectively bred mob are
the bread lotus founders are our model
for internalizing disorder and the bread
high responders are model for
externalizing disorders there is a
question mark because I would like to
show you or fried convince you that this
actually is the case so first I need to
tell you that when we start we don't
know who's going to be full but by the
twentieth way before that but if this is
an example of the twenty third
generation we know with about 90%
certainty how we're gonna classify them
as high or low responders even if we
don't know even if you haven't yet
tested them we can pre classify them
based on their families we know this is
the high responder lineage the offspring
are going to be fire responders by now
it's like a hundred percent sure we know
what they're going to be when they grow
up it's very clearly genetic we have
data analysis of pedigrees classic
genetic analysis that shows that this
tree is very clearly genetically
transmitted to both males and females
from both mothers and fathers and over
the years we've characterized of
a lot of different traits in them
they're anxiety depression that was
supposed to fear their aggression
impulsivity how they respond to
environmental cues that mean reward and
whether they love drugs
or not and I want to put out of the
picture the fact that one is smart and
the other is dumb they are not different
in their ability to learn so again a
breadth B means the bread high and low
responder animals so first let's look at
the internalizing traits and very early
on from this paper in 2006 with John
stead we showed that when we selectively
read for this locomotion in a new
environment we also differentiate them
in measures of anxiety and we have a
number of measures of anxiety one that
I'm showing you is the elevated plus
maze where an animal can either choose
to go literally out on the limb of an
open arms of elevated plus maze or stay
very safe between walls and when we look
at our high and low responder animals we
see that the high responders are up
there checking out the open arms the no
responders are very at the bottom are
very conservative and these differences
we can see them in the open field in the
light dark box and this graph shows you
that in the open field in green the high
responders for example go to the center
a lot in the top panel the low
responders know but if you give them
benzodiazepines like a valium then the
low responders go right out and
indistinguishable from the high
responders whereas the the high
responders do not really profit or for
laughs from the benzodiazepines for
example you know there isn't a very big
difference here with the benzos in the
high responders but there is a very big
difference in the benzos well Otis found
it they respond more and it eases their
anxiety similarly when this is a test
where you put animals in water the first
time and you find out whether they died
or not this is a day-to-day test the
first day everybody tries to get out
like the second day they kind of learn
this folk learned helplessness they
learn that it's useless some animals
learn faster than others is predicts
whether they're going to respond to an
antidepressant and the low responders
become helpless faster than the high
responders first day they look the same
the second day they try to climb less
and again if you give them
antidepressants the antidepressants help
the load is founded so they it this is
not just because they move more or less
they respond to the drugs differently
and this is a collaboration with Alice
Webb's lab in Pittsburgh where they give
a very mild unpredictable stress like
this noise a little kind of restraint
over a few weeks of life so the animals
aren't just fine enough alone they are
disturbed a little bit but it's not
enough to upset the high responders the
high responders stay pretty much the
same this is a test of whether they like
to drink sugar sucrose just for the
taste of it for the fun of it and that's
like a any Donia test whether you like
measures in life and that everybody
likes to drink sugar but the high
responders continue to do so even if
they're exposed to this mild stress but
the lordís founders just give up this is
the bottom dashed line showing that with
this stress intervention over a couple
of weeks the no responders just stopped
liking to drink the sugar and water so
this is an example of a loss of Padonia
or anhedonia that whether to which the
low responders are very vulnerable so
one question is does this phenotype seem
completely unshakable or can you change
it and we've done a number of things to
change it but I'm going to show you one
example which is called environmental
complexity and in this example all we do
is we put them in a bigger space and
give them toys we give them
and more toys nice the kid toys on a
daily basis over time and we watch what
happens and one of the things we do is
we also listen to them vocalize and
arrange that we can't hear it's 50
kilohertz but we have machines that can
detect it and what we find is that an
complex environment has a positive
effect but it really is different in the
high and low responder animals actually
it really again helps the no responders
the vulnerable animals so that it makes
them less anxious and it makes them emit
these positive noises much more actively
and that is definitely true
look at the right panel in the
environmental complexity after you give
it chronically the low responders become
just as positive emitting just as many
noises as the high responders and that
is a very big difference from the first
time that you give it where they're much
less excited in fact they're emitting in
another range that says there's someone
distress so repeated exposure through
the toys actually make them enjoy the
toys and if anything the high responder
amaz get bored with the toys over time
and they become a little more
rambunctious and aggressive so it's so
it does suggest that in the environment
matters that a positive environment
especially helps the high and low
responders and this is a summary from
the work that we published in 2013 by 4
s sepulveda R which shows that having
the presence of a buddy helps everybody
but especially the lowest founder
animals and that time also helps the low
responder animals become the mess
inhibited less anxious more positive
emit more positive noises so overall I
would say that the high and low
responders exhibit different coping
strategies to the environment where the
high responders are more active
dolorous founders are more passive I'm
not showing it to you but in fear
conditioning that's definitely the case
where the passive the typical response
is freezing when you've afraid but the
high responders don't want to freeze
they fight so you can see that this can
be considered adaptive or maladaptive
depending on the conditions but these
animals are genetically wired to show
you the response and we've made them
very extreme now on the externalising
trait side what we do see is the high
responders are more aggressive so when
we make them become territorial about
their problem and then somebody intrudes
they are much more willing to chase
after the intruder and the intruder is
much more likely to be scared of them
then when it's a little despondent as
event they also tend to be more
impulsive so remember the marshmallow
test that I told you about can you
control and delay your pleasure or
gratification in this study we asked
animals to delay for a bit before
pressing for food reward so the animals
must refrain and we ask them to refrain
for five ten twenty or thirty seconds
after there is a signal the signal says
there's food that's going to be coming
in that magazine right next to you and
the request is wait a bit before you
press the bar before you press the bar
and and you know before you then try and
eat but instead some animals press right
away and others animals are able to
delay so this is this study that shows
what happens ordinarily if there is no
DNA in in responding the high responders
press like crazy you can see that on the
left and and they press in general much
more but if you look at how many on the
right how many aren't effective in
getting you the food that you need
because you were able to wait then you
can see that the high responders in the
dark
are actually relatively ineffective and
the low responders are much more
effective and the more in the delay the
more you know the less effectiveness of
the high responders because they cannot
light so they are clearly more impulsive
there is this other phenomenon called
sign tracking and goal tracking and this
is now not a place where the animal has
to press anything it's just like
Pavlov's dogs where there is a signal
that comes on and that says you know pay
attention there's something good that's
gonna happen in a little while so the
the CS number is now actually serving as
that the bell in Pablo d'azyr's buddies
this is the conditioned stimulus it's
lit up and so when it pops up it makes
it always it's lit up and it says pay
attention in that food cup right next to
it there's going to be some M&Ms so
that's all the animals just have to
learn that associations it can be
playing around in the cage doing other
stuff and then when they see the signal
they know food is going to come and the
question is how do you feel about that
signal so this is like you're seeing
this fine of if you love coffee and
you're seeing the Starbucks side how do
you feel about that moment that's the
question
so there are some animals called sign
trackers who sort of fall in love with
that level with that sign and they they
go to it and they start chewing on it as
if it was free and that other animals
called road trackers who just know that
it's just a sign and they just over go
over to where the food is going to come
and wait for the food and we can
quantify this and what shall if they
know published in nature in 2011 is that
our high responder animals are sign
trackers they fall in love with the sign
the low responder animals are grown
tractors they learn the associations but
they just prefer to just wait for the
goodies and there is a series of studies
that I don't want to go into in great
detail but you can find it in that make
flagel clock at all that talks about
whether this is dependent on dopamine in
the brain and so we gave a blocker or
dopamine receptor blocker and we showed
that in fact the sign the sign trackers
side tracking requires dopamine in the
brain and that if you don't have
dopamine then the sign tracking response
is highly inhibited so we can follow the
flow of dopamine in the brain and we can
find that sign tracking is associated
with greater dopamine especially in the
high responder animals this is the study
that shows that playing ticks all which
is a blocker of the dopamine receptor is
critical for sign tracking but for
remembering sign tracking but not for
remembering rule tracking behavior so
with all this we can go back down to
addiction and ask if these animals these
high responders are genetically bred to
be more impulsive to sidetrack more can
do that desire effect they're likely to
become addicted now even in the are
great animals the animals that were
genetically bred we have replicated the
Piazza finding that the high responder
animals love to take drugs faster than
the no responder animals so how about
our this is a reminder actually that
there are two types of ways to really
wanna take drugs one is this the one I'm
describing where you do it for thrills
but there is a well known way that I'm
not talking about today where it is kind
of a type of self medication where
animals who are very anxious or
creatures who are very anxious take the
drug to feel better and we can also see
that and we see now in our low responder
at all so we can not a model bowls but
I'm focusing on the high responder
thrill-seeking aspect of substance abuse
here and this is a study that is now in
fest in PNAS that Shelley flagel did
where she gave them a very long period
for animals to have a chance to get a
dick
it's called extended access so she made
sure that animals don't take different
amounts of drugs so please specify the
amount of drugs that the animals can
take the high responders took it in the
first five minutes we then stopped
access for them it's the low responders
took an hour to get to that level of
drug thinking we gave them the four
hours so over time they got exposed to
the same amount of drugs and over time
everybody got addicted it's just that
the high responders did it faster but
everybody got the same exposure to the
drug and then there was a period where
we maintain them and now they look
pretty identical to each other everybody
was equally a different then we put them
through an abstinence period you can see
that those periods in the bar at the top
and then we gave them a chance to want
to take drugs and then go abstinent and
then ask them if we show you a fuel
that's associated with the drug will you
relapse so skew is shown in the diagram
which shows that you can actually just
have a life that comes on when the drug
is available and eventually the animal
associate that cue with the blood and
now when you remove the drug and you
just show the life does the animal have
an urge to see the drug this is kind of
like seeing a needle or being in a place
that was associated with drug use for an
addict to see if they're likely to
relapse or the social contacts and so
what we have found is that these high
responder animals are have many features
are associated with addictive behavior
so if you remove the drug associated few
suddenly the animals are affected if
they are high responded but not Laura's
father so then they're responding to the
whole context like SCI trackers they
after prolonged the administration the
high responders not the low responders
start to seek the drug on their own even
if it's not there anymore and if you do
that pure removal that I told you even
after a whole month of
abstinence and you asked who is going to
go you know banging on the lover to try
and get the drug it's the high
responders that do it way more than the
law responders so in other words they're
not just acquiring the drug perfectly
which is what has been shown before in
the non genetically bred animals but
they're showing all the signs of
addiction which means greater relapse
greater drug seeking a greater
association of the drug to a whole bunch
of other contextual cues and again this
work is interests and can be followed up
so we have generally then shown you that
many behavioral traits are different
even though we bred on this one
behavioral test which is will you
explore things more and one of the
questions and how when did that happen
so are there are there critical
developmental events that are associated
with this phenotype this for complex
phenotype so firstly how quickly can we
detect this in our animals and and this
paper by Clinton at all looked at first
of all whether the mothers are different
and then how quickly we can detect it
and just a reminder that a good mother
rat spends a lot of time art arched over
her baby she licks them she suckles I'm
a bad mother leaves the baby is kind of
alone and go shopping what I say she
goes shopping or is very passive about
it she just sits there and they lets
them seek it and we found that hi Andrew
responded mothers are different but
they're different
this is changes over the first and
second week why and it changes in the
mic versus the dark so in a nutshell
when the hi responder animals are during
the dark period which is the active
period they're more distracted and they
do less active mothering the low
responder and moms are very kind of
active in with their babies and less
active in the environment but over the
second we
there is quite a bit of compensation and
it looks like everybody actually gets
some decent mothering just the timing is
different and this is a study when we
did cross-fostering and again it's
complex but it shows that those letters
are reacting differently to their own
pups to the pups different facts that
aren't their own and it depends on
whether the other pup is active or is
not active so the maternal styles are
not just genetic they are responding to
the pump itself and they're different
during the light and the dark so
everything is in their gene environment
interaction between mother and pop are
all interacting early on in life to
further shape the differences in
behaviour meanwhile high and low
responder animals that are just raised
by their moms show very early
differences in their propensity to you
know in the inviting saya T
locomotion we can see it as early as we
can measure it
this is differences in the open field
and the light dark box on day 25 of age
and what is interesting is that is not
in the end affected by food takes care
of it so those genetic traits are very
strong and immune to differences in
mothering it's only in the middle in the
animals that aren't so extreme that the
mothering differences make a difference
on anxiety behavior but on the extremes
it's more genetic relatives paternal
behavior now we have done a number of
rain studies to look at what genes are
getting turned on at what point in life
and in in aberrant animals we found that
the second week of life is really
important and we here show that in the
high and low responder animals in the
bottom we're encoding them this is Hall
a brain gene expression profiling by
micro arrays we show that the biggest
difference is between high and low
responders are occurring more in the
hippocampus than in the nucleus
accumbens
chose these two areas because
hippocampus is relevant to stress and
anxiety and context the nucleus
accumbens is in substance abuse so it's
really more than hippocampus as
different and the leftmost bar shows
that the biggest differences are on
seven days of life and they actually the
differences are reduced later on in life
so these differences in the brain as a
whole and in benefi campus in particular
are laid down early they show up by the
first week of life of the animal this is
an example of some genes and their
differences by you can see at p7 in the
hippocampus there are 600 transcripts
that differentiate high and low
responder and that number diminishes by
even they 21 and the differences in
accumbens are lower so this is all to
say that there is plenty of genetic
basis for these differences that we we
then have embarked on a way of
genotyping these animals by crossing and
recrossing them and we have data on a
lot of them but this work is still in
progress we have some early exome
sequencing in collaboration with David
Coleman at NIH that is already
identifying some genes that are
different between our two lines of
animals but there are more studies that
are following up where we're viewing
home genome sequencing with doing RNA
sequencing in the brain and we're going
to try and hone in on the specific genes
that predict the specific traits that
determine let's say the anxiety plays
versus the drug seeking free and then we
hope to take that back to the upper ed
animals because that's what most people
work on and validate which ones are
modifying behavior and of course go back
and ask whether the humans show some of
these same genetic propensities and how
we can use that to predict vulnerability
or resilience and again I want to
emphasize that that in most cases this
doesn't spell that you're going to be an
addict
you're going to be depressed but a
tendency of our ability now if I have a
few minutes what I want to do is just
give you quickly one example of how
we've used these animals to follow up on
some human discoveries and this is where
we're using the high and low responder
animals to study in genes that come from
the work of this pritzker consortium
where in the consortium we study
genetics of psychiatric disorders and we
also study the brains of people who have
died with diagnosis of illness and in
the process we identify genes and brain
molecules transcripts that are different
in their levels and activities in
depressed people versus control or
bipolar or schizophrenia this is about
depression so the example is the
fibroblast growth factor family which we
ten years ago identified as being really
different in the brain of the flesh the
humans compared to control and we then
asked is this just a chance or can we
study it in our animal models we started
in the upper end animals and we use this
model for social defeat where there is a
social stress like I showed you before
and one animal wins and the other loses
and we showed that them one of the
molecules that we should we had
identified as being low in depression at
Jeff two becomes also know in animals
that are socially stressed in the
different regions of the hippocampus
it's quite a profound decrease showing
that the decrease in the human might be
secondary to the depression or to the
social stress of the depression I'm
sorry this did not come through but this
is a study by Turner at all that shows
that if you actually give at Jeff to in
in the rat you can produce an
antidepressant effect as if it was our
own natural antidepressant so you can
give it literally or centrally and make
the animal act as
it is less depressed more interesting
even is what happens if you shut down or
knock down the natural level of fgf in
the brain this is in the dentate gyrus
of the hippocampus and we showed again
in outlet animals that we can use a
viral vector we can reduce the
expression of FG a fool in the dentate
gyrus and when we do this by you know
more than half when we do this we get
animals that act more anxious in this
one thing is anxiety exploration test
this is the elevated plus maze that
shows that the animals are who have
lower fgf2 in their hippocampus spend
more time in the closed arms of the
elevated plus veins that's the right
hand most of a part and less in the
center in the open arms so if tf2 is a
natural endogenous antidepressant and
anti-anxiety substance so how about we
look at it in our high and low responder
animals and you will find that naturally
the low responder animals if we don't do
anything to them have lower levels of
this natural antidepressant in their
hippocampus especially in the dentate
gyrus where I just showed you that it's
active as an engineer so you can argue
that they have less of this natural anti
anxiety substance in their brain
genetically and if we give it externally
repeatedly it reverses anxiety in them
selectively again without affecting the
high responders so this is what I call
precision medicine for the rats
if you don't have no fgf in your brain
you don't need fgf but if you have no
objection in your brain you give it to
you externally suddenly you are less
anxious you are less the class and we
have shown that this is associated with
increase neurogenesis now that's the
good news about fgf2 it kind of
ameliorates the anxiety and depression
phenotypes in the Norris founder well
what does it do in terms of substance
abuse when we have shown
that that it actually if you give it
neonatal e and you watch the animal go
through life and then you watch what
happens as adults they actually increase
that are taking behavior so in fact what
is really interesting is that we can
give h fu once from the first day of
life and watch them grow up and watch
how it gypped rewrites the program of
the hi and notice father animals so you
if you that single injection of fgf2 in
the animal and then testing the animals
as adults makes the low responders less
anxious so what you see in the in the
solid bars here is what the out-breath
high and low responder animal I mean the
untreated high and low responder animals
look like that you can see very dramatic
differences in the time strength in the
open arms of the elevator + main means
with the Lotus founders being very
inhibited but when we give fgf2 to the
animals and on the first day of life and
let them grow to be adults what we find
is that the Lotus founders are now less
anxious they're not as adventuresome as
the high responders because those guys
are really crazy but they are more like
what a normal mid-level animals would be
so here once again is that kind of
tailored precision medicine for rats it
helps the low responders but now in a
developmental way so and the other thing
is I showed you I mentioned that it
increases the propensity to self
administer for pain in our bread animals
it also increases sensitization to
cocaine but only in the world is fonder
animals so basically what it does is
switches the phenotype a little bit away
from being low responders and a little
bit more towards the middle or closer to
being high responded one shot of fgf2
and this is all gone through epigenetic
modification so we have shown that FGF 2
3
a lot of neonate only triggers
epigenetic modifications that are
lifelong I don't want to go into the
details here it's for you to look at in
this PNAS paper in 2014 when we have
shown that from the epigenetic
standpoint
early life [ __ ] makes the no responded
more similar to the high responders
there are other players in the FDF
family fgf 9 goes in the opposite
direction and the low and high responder
animals this is a paper in PNAS it's
just a fear that a few months ago by at
least our back and you can look at it
but the punchline is there is a yin and
yang at TF 2 is your endogenous
antidepressant and NZ lytic fgf 9 is the
endogenous Pro depressant through
anxiety and then you opposite things and
the high and low responder animals have
helped us show that that is in fact the
case in our animal models so we have
used the animal models to show that fgfe
is a vulnerability gene is a
developmental gene is important in
stress in neural remodeling and this is
just one of many examples where this
model has helped us study the biology of
particular molecules that we want to
implicate in mood and temperament and
substance abuse so in other words I feel
that we can think of temperament as a
program that causes different reactions
to the environment and that there are
switch genes on what I four master
organizers and fgf who is one example of
them that play a role both genetically
but developmentally environmentally
epigenetically and in adulthood to
moderate modulate system for mental
tendencies and change the reactivity to
the environment and these would be
really interesting targets for us in
human studies I think that these better
moms that think about emotional
reactivities might turn out to be very
helpful in finding better tailored
strategies for the treatment of
psychiatric and I thank you thank you
doctor Akhil for being that excellent
presentation to us before we get started
on our questions I want to remind the
attendees how to submit them questions
can be submitted via the green Q&A
button at the lower left when we have
questions already in our queue will get
to the first dr. Kiehl one of our
attendees asks do you believe this could
lead to new treatments the depression
disorders in the future
and findings and continuously refine our
strategies until we can come up with the
completely different classes of
treatment for these disorders because
the current treatments have all been
more or less variations on a theme with
SSRIs and the noradrenergic there is
ketamine which is very interesting and
exciting but in general we do not have
brand new modalities for treatment and
this is pointing us to completely
different ways but the other thing I
want to say is that these could also be
biomarkers and that's very important the
idea that not all people are the same
that they're going to respond
differently including to drugs is very
critical and if we could say if you have
this gene you are more likely to respond
to this treatment and if you have that
gene you're more likely to respond to
that people might be incredibly powerful
and helpful to honing in on the right
treatment much more effectively great
our next question can impulsive
aggressive nature of the high responding
mice turn out to be anxious at any
moment can you repeat that please
of course our attendee asks can
impulsive aggressive nature of the bhrs
the high responders turn out to be
anxious at any moment yes yes the answer
is yes so these animals are very
sensitive to their environment in their
own way and if you stress them in the
right conditions or socially isolate
them they can be quite anxious and in
fact there are treatments exposure tools
even mild stress in adolescence in
particular that have opposite
effects on our two lines so that no
responders if they are exposed to some
measure of stress as they are developing
become more resilient in adulthood but
the high responders actually become less
resilient and more anxious so there is a
lot of interaction and it's it's it's
not a one phenotype is not better
protected it's just simply different and
so yes they can become very stressed and
aggressive thank you our next question
dr. Aquila great conference the question
is have you encountered similar
information regarding high responder and
low responder differences and an animal
model such as a zebrafish that is really
interesting I have not but I do believe
that this tendency to explore or not
until we act is going to be universal
and in fact I have seen work on forms
that suggests that some worms tolerate
the changes in their environment more
than others and if they if you change
their environment a little bit some ways
kind of stateful and others will go
exploring
I think this exploratory tendency and
how it's tuned in a species is a very
very basic fundamental survival of the
species feature that it's there in flies
and worms and zebrafish and mice and
rats and humans might have affected you
know who migrated to emigrate emigrates
to other countries I think it's a very
fundamental traits because it's
important for a species to have this
variation in order for the species as a
whole to survive sometimes there's too
much threat and everybody's a high
responders of all species would
disappear so you need those low
responders and vice versa
need explorers so I think it's going to
be there anyway
great thank you our next question what
about local motor activity in the
animals so locomotion is a very big part
of this and obviously the test is a
locomotive s so a question is always
weather are you only looking at just
more movement are you just leaving
animals to move more or does that is it
oriented to something specific so no
corrosion can be random or it can be
role oriented we're interested in the
goal oriented locomotion when we started
the bleeding our animals were not
different in their homepage everybody
locomotive the same but they were
different in a new environment as we
bred them more and more we have seen
that our high responders are generally
more active even in their home page so
we have red hyperactive animals by now
so we're always careful to try and sort
out whether what we're looking at is
just the result of increased locomotion
non-specifically or if it is specific
for an example in self-administration
studies we always have two buttons or
tuning holes for the animal to work on
or for we have an active one where does
the woodies and there is an inactive one
and we always correct for just
nonspecific activity so eventually we
have bred for higher locomotion but in
general everything I have thrown team is
separable from that and has an affective
component to it which is what we're
interested in
great thank you we do have time for one
last question my question is have the
objections of fgf2 been tested on limits
so again that's a great question we are
interested in doing that but the problem
is if v 2 is very powerful in general so
it's powerful in inducing growth in the
periphery and the concern is if somebody
is prone to cancer or anything like that
we don't want to give them a powerful
factor so we can't really probably give
up gf in any continuous way we have a
number of strategies we're trying there
are partners of fgf2 that only work in
the brain we're interested in them
there are mimics that might work in
brain better than the rest of the body
were interested in them and we're also
interested in the fact that fgf 9 works
in the opposite direction so if we could
walk fgf 9 maybe we could do we could do
the same thing so we have a number of
ideas and strategies to pursue this and
we're actually the physical consortium
is actively for something that we
definitely want to use it both as a
biomarker and as a potential treatment
target and it's one of many that we have
from the consortium i've happened to
focus on it but i am pleased that it's
been replicated by other people other
labs both in human and animals so i
think it's a viable of which thank you
so much dr. Kiehl we are just about out
of time I'd like to thank dr. Kiel again
for bringing this presentation to us the
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September of 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this broadcast is available for
on-demand play and we invite you to fall
with that announcements to any
colleagues may have missed today's live
broadcast thank you again for logging on
we hope to see you next time goodbye